I've physically done every job in the
business I don't think that I'm too
special to go out and actually go and
get nurses compliant for example I'm one
of the first to go out and actually sort
of do the necessary to get the nurses to
buy into us I want to make them remember
me remember the company just start going
that extra while it's going to be
difficult as you grow and I'm finding it
a bit difficult now because I don't know
all the nurses any longer it's about
instilling that same sort of ethos to
the team making sure that they
understand that this is what you need to
do welcome back to another episode of
the recruitment mentors podcast I'm your
host Hisham azuz and on this week's
episode I was joined by Hannah Ahmed she
started a business called a HG group
where their bread and butter is
recruiting nurses for the NHS after
working for the NHS for five years then
working for a recruitment business for
another five years she took the leap to
start her entrepreneurial journey and it
has not been easy to say the least we
discuss everything here on how Hannah
got on to to the framework so she could
start working with the NHS she ended up
buying a business from someone based in
India just to get into these Frameworks
we spoke about how she found herself in
a position where they were owed over a
million pounds in invoices and Hannah's
been on a real growth Journey she's
consistently gone out of her comfort
zone she felt pregnant unexpectedly
during this journey as well we spoke
about that just pure honesty pure
authenticity on this episode I
absolutely loved sitting down with
Hannah have the utmost respect for her
and have no doubt she's going to
continue to build a successful
recruitment business enjoy Hannah
welcome to the podcast Thank you very
looking forward to this not gonna lie
I've got I've got to call it out here
but you definitely won the award for the
latest guess I'm so sorry do you know
what anyone that knows me will tell you
that my punctuality is probably
why didn't you tell me that I should
have told you that the podcast is at
half ten one of them ones and you know
what I also blame the fact that my
assistant
yeah I'm really sorry about that that's
cool good luck so really looking forward
to unpacking this journey that you've
been on I think as we're just saying
over the last sort of um four and a half
years you've been on your own
entrepreneurial Journey building HD
group yeah so in today's sort of uh
conversation we're going to really focus
on that but before that just to add some
uh flavor and context for everyone you
worked for a other another recruitment
business for nearly five years correct
before that you worked in the NHS for
five years yeah and then before that
there's actually a debate yeah it's a
debt collector for one girl I saw that
the news and did some real bad things so
five years NHS collections manager debt
collector five years in Recruitment and
then for the last nearly yeah four and a
half years you've been on your own um
entrepreneurial Journey so God is it
four and a half years that's what it
says on LinkedIn wow um wow yeah okay so
let me let me add some context here then
just for everyone
um just for everyone to understand so I
think maybe with what you just said so I
think you shared with me the start in
2018 but had covenants Etc so it wasn't
things didn't really start kicking on
until uh 2019. I would say yeah from
February that when all my sort of
restrictions were sort of lifted yeah so
and I just I felt like that was the
right time to kind of come back into
Healthcare and and make my mark cool so
from yeah from around Feb 2019
um really kicked on in in the healthcare
space again in the HG group so just to
add some uh context here so basically
um where you over the last couple of
years there's some there's some crazy
stories in here which I'm really looking
forward to uncovering but in terms of
like where you are today
um let me just get down to it sorry uh
okay cool so basically I think you've
got three different brands that's
um in terms of 2022
um the revenue was 5.5 million correct
net profit last year was 400 Grand
that's correct and then I think like
today you're at 18 people in total
you've got six people around six people
Finance five people in compliance and
seven people in sales yeah and that
number's growing actually we've been
hiring so yeah that's accurate for now
but we've probably looking at
trying to get to around 25 by the end of
April yeah so yeah I know your the
revenue goal this year is to get 10 10
million and net profit 1.5 million
profit is is the go is the big 2023 goal
that that is yeah that's where we'd like
to be yeah I love that and then so the
brands as well we've got nursing that's
sort of being your bread and butter as
you said uh being branching into doctors
and then also private I think you put I
don't know private healthcare private
clients Home Care contracts we're
looking at setting up
um more Home Care a Home Care Division
and we've got the ahp division that we
want to try and sort of drive as well
this year so there's quite a lot of
plans to try and get the other staff
groups moving but for me it's more
important to make sure we Master the
nursing side and do well in that before
we try and sort of
look at other avenues yeah Okay cool so
that's just for everyone listening
that's some context to like obviously
we've brushed over a lot A lot has
happened to get to that point right so
let's start with the million pound
question something that I'm sure you've
thought long and hard about since
growing your own recruitment business
what is Hannah's take in terms of what
characteristics and traits do you
believe make up a highly successful
recruitment consultant in today's market
let's start there wow wow for me it
really consists of resilience you've got
to have a lot of resilience because
you're going to be getting a lot of no's
especially in healthcare majority of
healthcare recruitment agencies are
fishing from the same pond so the nurses
are kind of speaking to everybody so
you've got to kind of differentiate
yourself and make sure you've got a
personality because there's not much in
the pay rates that you're offering so
it's personality resilience you've got
to have some real drive as well to
ensure that you are able to get those
nurses to buy into you which is really
important
the other characteristics is just being
able to have empathy because most of the
nurses that we deal with the healthcare
professionals you are kind of an
extension of their own family you're
helping them make money you know they're
reliant on your expertise to get them
work for their own sort of livelihoods
so you've got to have a lot of empathy
because there's times that they might
things might go wrong with um
pay you know they might have sort of
other sort of things that are going on
in their personal lives that they want
to speak to you about and just being
kind be in kind to them I think
being very driven it's very important
and just um being relentless because it
is a Relentless job so I think if you
have those characteristics you'll you'll
go far and you just gotta some people
give up quite quickly and easily or just
maybe procrastinate in recruitment you
can't procrastinate other people will
take your work and it's a really
um Relentless job I'd say yeah so
resilience empathy
personality being authentic building
relationships okay so I like I said to
you when we prepared for this
um for whatever reason I haven't sat
down with many uh Healthcare recruitment
entrepreneurs no idea why so I am I'm
I'm like so curious to sort of learn I
guess some of the things that you've had
to work through
um sort of the things that you you've
done to sort of be successful and grow
your
um business so I guess let's just let's
just start with what what do you believe
it take to sort of from your experience
so far to be successful in the
healthcare Market specifically the nicer
Market because like like you've just
said from my sort of minimal experience
that I've had either working with
recruitment businesses in that space
recruitment is competitive but in this
in your sort of world it seems even more
competitive like I always remember
recruiters saying oh I might have a
nurse or a mental health nurse that
would basically just pick the other
recruiter because they can pay me 15p
more or something like that they are the
most unloyal unfortunately as much as I
love my nurses they're so not loyal to
anyone really they're loyal to their
pocket so you've got to have something
extra too so what is that extra thing
because that that must be so hard you
personality you've got to have character
you've got to be able to have chat
normal conversations call them when it's
not sometimes phone them when it's not
even about work you know see how they're
getting on you know they like personable
people and obviously people that can
empathize with their long shifts low pay
you know all of that sort of stuff so I
think that helps but again if Joe blogs
down the road is paying a pound more
um
you might have a problem yeah that's
that's tough so this is why don't we
just start here then so obviously if
things yeah really started to kick on
because you was out of your covenants
you could get back into the market that
you've obviously built relationships in
work really hard in in 2019 like what
was Hannah's mindset to making HG group
different like what what was the initial
thoughts on the differentiator because
if you literally are yeah like it's so
like working on price or like in your
Market is so competitive on price yeah
how what was your initial sort of
strategy or thoughts on how we're going
to make a difference
um I think because I was in the NHS for
a number of years I started out in the
NHS when I was quite young so working as
an account manager I got good insight to
knowing how sort of Staff Banks you know
Healthcare sector sort of works in the
NHS and it's all about cost and what you
can do to obviously try and reduce costs
um compliance is very important as well
in in the NHS as well so making sure
that you have you know dotted the is
cluster T's they really are a stickler
for just costs so you know selling a
service I mean when I was at my um old
recruitment company the main ethos was
high volume low margin which I really
stood by I really believed in that
product because I felt that that was
what differentiated us from the other uh
when you say high volume what would you
mean so just basically
when we were training the Consultants or
the you know making sure that they
understood they had to fill a lot of
shifts to make money
um and from a sort of healthcare trust
NHS perspective should I say
um they want to obviously make savings
and it's all about selling to them you
know oh look we're high volume we make
our margin from filling a lot of your
shifts not a few of your shifts so that
always worked for us in terms of just
making sure that they understood that we
weren't going to make you know 50 pounds
an hour from one nurse that we're
actually here to fill you know as many
shifts as possible because we work on a
volume sort of based margin and that's
how we we've operated in HD as well so
it's more so high high volume low margin
so what I'd love to understand then
because back to your point of the
importance of
connecting Personality yeah how do you
achieve like for me that must it was
surely like that must be quite
transactional
it is listen the demographics of nurses
in in the healthcare Healthcare sector
in in London is predominantly they've
got you know it's quite diverse right
you've got your African demographic
you've got your Filipino Community
you've got your
um Portuguese community so there's
different communities and trust me for
me starting up in the business I was
going to weddings I was going to
christenings I was going to church I'm
Muslim I was going to church
I was going to church I was in the
church service with them you know what
I'm saying so for me uh that's how you
that's how you become memorable to to
those nurses because you are there with
them you've got nurses bringing pots of
Joel off rice to the office that's the
sort of person personality that you need
to have you need to be able to relate to
them even if you don't necessarily
that's not your Walk of Life be prepared
to be able to sort of sit down with them
eat with them I was going into nurses
houses certain foods you know obviously
it's not to my sort of taste but I was
eating the food you know just needing to
get build build a rapport build a
rapport and trust me it's Relentless
because there's stuff that you've got to
do to kind of get yourself out there and
make sure that the nurses know that
you're there and then you know Word of
Mouth then you know Auntie down the road
now knows you now she wants to come and
work with you and it just ends up being
a community of different nurses but the
demographics is important I think go in
and actually trying to
sort of going to their weddings going to
christensen's going to church what hours
just really commit to trying to connect
yeah
because I guess I guess the reason for
that from what understanding is
basically if if like Hannah the nurse
recruiter is always sort of vulnerable
to one of your nurses being called up
and saying hey so-and-so like I can get
you this shift it's going to be paying
you a pound more like you're very
vulnerable to them going yeah I'm going
to take that yeah however you're
building that and that's why it's really
important because they want to go well
you know what like Hannah like Hannah
I've like Hannah's helped me a lot yeah
so you need to invest in these
relationships so much for them to go you
know what I'm not going to take that
[__] but it's a pound more exactly it
was to be hard though if you're in if
you're you're yeah it's high volume
that's that's the thing that that's hard
that's physically done every job in the
business I haven't shied away from I
don't think that I'm too special to go
out and actually go and get nurses
compliant for example like my team will
will tell you that I'm one of the first
to go out and actually sort of do the
necessary to get the nurses to buy into
us and most of the time when they find
out I'm the owner like what you're the
owner I'm like yeah you know I want to I
want to make them remember me and
remember the company you know and just
just start going that extra mile it's
going to be difficult as you grow and
I'm finding it a bit difficult now
because as we grow I'm not able I don't
know all the nurses any longer my team
know them and have those relationships
so it's about instilling that same sort
of ethos to the team and making sure
that they understand that this is what
you need to do so let's just talk about
them so obviously we've spoken a bit
about yeah how he's thinking about being
different when he's starting an HG group
in the healthcare space so then I think
the other really sort of nuanced part to
your world is then the sort of business
development and getting jobs right
because if you're working with the NHS
yeah then there's this word Frameworks
right so let's just talk about that and
maybe for those that don't know what
this is right could you just explain so
if I'm if I have a recruitment business
and I work with NHS yeah what is a
framework and why is that important from
a client like having a job to work yeah
from having jobs to work perspective
like what what is a framework basically
so the framework and if Stephanie or any
of the workforce alliances listening hi
guys I'm gonna try and do my best to
sell you in the right light yeah just
you can educate us because yeah so the
framework is basically a sort of body
that regulates the agencies to make sure
that they are
following the NHS sort of employers
standard of recruitment so it's May
predominantly about the compliance of
the nurse and making sure that they're
actually eligible to go out and work
um and you have to go through a massive
tender process to actually be on that
framework that framework and you also
have to work provide evidence that
you've been able to provide and Supply
nurses
um obviously if you haven't worked in
the NHS before you're even not going to
be on the framework and you may well get
into a few hospitals but if you really
want to look at longevity you need to be
on the frame you need to be in the
Frameworks so that is the most important
bit because the first question that most
um
Health NHS hospitals sort of ask is
basically are you on the framework right
and if you're not
nine times out of ten if you don't if
you don't if you don't have the
framework then you won't get the work
because it's just more hassle for them
if you're not on the framework yeah
because that kind of gives them the
assurance that you're regulated right
it's not a sort of so it's not a
regulated body if that makes sense but
they they have the power to kind of
remove you from the framework they do
checks every year and audits to make
sure that you're following the correct
processes by the way we just passed as
well let's go just passed on Monday we
just passed out so I guess the reason
why we're talking about this is because
in your world like fair to say then that
you can let me know but is it fair to
say that if you have a recruitment
business in the healthcare space and you
want to provide staff for the NHS that
for you to like yeah I guess achieve
some sort of big success you're probably
likely going to be have to be on the
framework yeah and when I started the
business I wasn't on the free exactly so
let's talk about that because there's a
story in here that I definitely want you
to share so I think this is why that's
why that's important right because
you're starting your own recruitment
business it's in the healthcare how the
hell does Hannah who's starting this
business from our bedroom get onto these
NHS Frameworks because obviously you
understood that that's pretty essential
yeah if we want to scale and and Achieve
what you want to so talk us through how
the hell did you achieve that so we were
doing a bit of work in the private
sector and um just wasn't sort of work
that I was used to in the volume so I
brought in a couple of recruiters they
were starting to get a bit sort of
anxious because they weren't seeing the
work coming in and I thought
can I swear yeah what am I gonna do
because they joined you like they I I
sold them the dream I was like guys
listen we're going to be so rich we're
gonna do this let's go it's gonna it's
gonna take off like I had to sell until
my heart was content and they believed
in me and came across but one of them
and I won't say his name one of them he
within a month I suppose he sort of
started saying look you know we're not
getting any work he was very sort of
agitated by the fact that we weren't
getting the work and what have you and I
thought what am I going to do man so I
thought okay I need to get on the
framework so I found out that the
framework weren't going to be sort
published for at least another year and
I thought [__] what am I going to do
right so what does that mean so
so right okay we couldn't sort of apply
to be on the framework another year and
I thought I can't wait a year so I
started looking at all of the lists of
agencies I'm also the ones that were
dormant that were awarded onto the
framework the last sort of the last
round so every four years you can sort
of apply to be on the framework and some
people go on it but they don't ever
Supply and I thought okay I'm going to
start going through this list and I just
was going through the list phoning all
these different agencies seeing if they
were still sort of trading and I think
we had like seven different deals on the
table
and I really wanted to make sure that we
got a deal where we didn't have any ties
to the agency anything like and I found
this one agency and the guy was in India
and he was prepared to sell
I thought
happy days so what was he selling to you
the so for you to be able to go like
yeah just so we understand not high
level what was he selling to you for me
to acquire his business his and that
would then mean you can go when and some
when's a hospital goes Hannah are you
guys on a frame or you can go yeah yeah
so basically he was India at the time he
had this agency that the agency was
called honitage recruitment at the time
um but he wasn't doing anything with it
but he was on a framework so he was just
someone that just basically got on the
framework didn't do anything with it and
just you know Relentless as I said phone
in so many uh different agencies getting
so many no's or deals that were just
crazy to find this guy who was in India
and he was willing to sell at a
reasonable price Happy Days Happy Days
took me four weeks to get that deal I
was going to say how long did it take
from like you picking up one of your
colleagues like look what's going on
here yeah we had one deal where we got
as far as the point of actually drafting
at the paperwork and then we realized I
didn't have the nursing the law for
nursing we were like [__] yeah that
would have been something yeah we can't
we can't buy this we can't do anything
with it we can't do anything with the
the staff group that we actually want to
sort of build they don't even have it so
the deal fell through and then I found
this guy and four weeks four weeks and
you know what I was in so much fear I
was so anxious the entire time because I
thought if he just doesn't answer his
phone this Deal's gone but I got it over
the line end of June love that um so
that was June 2019. wow okay so I guess
what would be good to talk about now
then is
your like your perspective of
um so there will be like you just said
there's a lot of agencies on these
Frameworks now just because you're in a
framework doesn't mean you're going to
be successful and you're going to be
able to do a bunch of work and be
successful so I guess why don't we just
talk about for a second like now you're
on the Frameworks what was the strategy
or how can you like what was your
approach to maximize now being on the
framework because like like you've just
said like you went through the whole
list some of them are dormant some of
them might not be getting the most out
of it just because you're on it doesn't
mean that's guaranteed success yeah so
it means we've got the hospitals yeah
the hospitals the hospitals it's a bit
of a saturated Market at the end of the
day and most of the main contenders in
the industry are the ones that are
getting the work so to come in as a new
sort of agency and try and get work it
can be difficult because if you don't
have those relationships from before
then the buy-in isn't really there
there's you're just another agency
that's going to say that you can sell
and get loads of people you know to work
and you can fill all their shifts but
reality is you might have two people on
your on your books and that's all you
can feel so I think the relationship at
the beginning with the NHS and my time
in the NHS really helped you really
leverage that yeah definitely so what
would your advice be for someone that
like doesn't have that if they're
listening to this knowing the healthcare
them to go and work in an NHS hospital
really I told them to go and try and
work in a staff bank if they can get
knowledge in the staff Banks make build
your relationships because staff Banks I
feel like they are literally the best
people what's the staff Bank sort of
manages the temporary staffing banks are
the ones that sort of manage the
um
the bank and agency you feel in the NHS
Hospital hospitals right so if you have
good relationships with the different
staff Banks you can
um sort of learn a lot about the NHS
learn about the different Services build
those relationships and then from there
go and work in an agency that's the way
around that I did it and that was the
best way for me to be honest that's
crazy then so like the the brands that
have been in the games the longest have
almost got a bit of a monopoly then they
have that's the biggest issue
I sort of
that's hard it's hard it's hard because
they are the people that have been in
the industry for 10 15 20 years they're
a name that's known
um and you've got to try and now
sort of go up against them but I'm
prepared to do that
we really are hey everyone a real quick
one from me this podcast would not be
possible without our amazing podcast
partners vincere and saucebreaker
because you listen to this podcast you
were able to get your hands on exclusive
savings on both of these award-winning
products if you're all a growing
recruitment business you have to check
out Vin Cherry who are an all-in-one
operating system for your growing
recruitment business with Source breaker
if you want to make sure that all of
your recruiters have the best tools on
the market to stand out and beat their
competition then you have to check out
Source breaker use the link in the show
notes in the comments below and you'll
be able to get yourself exclusive
savings on these amazing products yeah
no I love that okay cool so no yeah
great yeah that's honestly so
interesting and this is just so unique
to the the healthcare industry yeah so
why don't we then talk about like you as
a business owner some of the the things
that we've had to to learn along the way
right because then if you're
um obviously supporting I'm paying a
bunch of nurses then finances and back
offers become important right well
massively important so let's just talk
about this so like what was because like
you've been on a whole journey on this
right and I think this would be really
helpful for people even for people
outside of
um the healthcare industry that have a
sort of big temp contract book and these
things so before you went on the whole
journey of getting
um things in order like what was like
Hannah's approach to the back office
paying in the nurses like do you know
what I mean what was like the initial
approach to being able to to do that to
be honest the initial approach was that
we we worked with a back office
um finance company to Outsource that we
outsourced it and to be fair they did a
good job okay so from from the start you
outsourced it it was from the very start
and I am glad that we did that at the
beginning because I that's not my area
of expertise at all I'm sales I I go out
and win business but to I've been
focusing on back office would have been
detrimental to the business to be honest
so it was good that we outsourced it to
start with and just so you understand
then so when you say Outsource like what
what does that actually look like so
they they they fund it and then they get
a percentage or like how does it
typically work so they basically manage
all your back office processes they
manage your payroll they manage your
accounts they do all of the necessary
pay your staff even your own sort of
like employees in the business they pay
them they do everything the 80 tax and
how do I get paid then is it oh you pay
them a retainer every month okay and the
retainer would kind of increase based on
how many timesheets they're processing
for the businesses right so it's
different brackets so yeah the more more
Yeah the more people that they process
sorry I just put this down yeah that's
fine um the more timesheets are process
the more they make okay cool that makes
sense so how long did you Outsource it
for
uh we only well the entire time we've
only just recently brought in our
payroll in-house in January okay oh
January this year yeah okay so talk to
me about okay maybe I'm not sure if I've
completely understood this you can help
me but where so if it com if it was
outsourced yeah how did you then get to
the point where you had like you said a
million pounds worth of debt or I owed
money how did that happen then
for
started there maybe and then you went to
try to do it more internal and then
that's where maybe things aren't picked
up yeah so that's exactly what happened
so last year yeah before um so at the
start of the year I brought some people
into the business start of this year
last year start of 2022. okay last year
last year yeah and I wanted to sort of
bring the back office functionality
in-house to stop Outsourcing that yeah
so we brought in a group Financial
controller yep and his job was to work
with person that we brought in to bring
it in in-house
but I don't think that unfortunately the
the the the knowledge wasn't there and
just around the stand so would that also
mean obviously to have the create the
systems processes to manage it all but
who what was you still going to
Outsource the funding or was HG group
going to fund it as well like fund the
nurses and the pets so so we have most
most agencies have an invoice
discounting facility okay so they would
sort of give you 90 or 85 of the invoice
value and they'll give it to you in
advance right they're able to then pay
the nurses okay that's something you
have to obviously build as well so that
back office company that we used
initially they helped massively yeah and
um the start of 2022 I bought these
these people in and I wanted more
visibility of the business because I was
really struggling on the back office
side and was you struggling with
specifically I'm not Finance I I don't I
don't
um I didn't have that knowledge this
overall getting your head around it
feeling like you're on top of it all
yeah I just was very confused by it all
um you know definitely an area that I
was shying away from because I just
didn't know it and I wanted to in 2022 I
was just like I need to learn I need to
understand what this all means for the
business I need to understand what the
accounts means I need to understand what
the profit and profit and loss means all
of that initially when I started I was
just like a sort of just driving the
cells driving sales driving sales just
get get you know get the framework in
place try and get our name out there
back office I had a company that was
managing it so it was manageable at the
time as we grew
the visibility I needed wasn't there and
I decided to bring people in but
unfortunately
um the combined knowledge wasn't there
and we made some real mistakes last year
huge mistakes so we brought in our back
office or we brought part of it back in
in-house and the reason why we got so
much debt is because we brought it in
and we didn't have an understanding of
exactly what needed to be done in the
background and you know unfortunately
lessons had to be learned from the
situation we had to take it back to the
back office company I mean an
implementation of back office takes at
least six months
um and we thought we could do it in a
month
it's just honestly diabolic diabolical
for me to think that we can bring in a
whole back office functionality in four
weeks
it's not it's not no it didn't work
um so we we
um
we went back to the back office company
and thankfully they sort of took us back
um but obviously in the time that they
weren't looking after the sort of Credit
Control uh functionality the debt
spiraled no one was chasing the debt and
in the end yeah people had your money in
the NHS if you're not if you're not on
top of your uh Credit Control they'll
leave your invoices until you sort of
come knocking at their door really
there's no real like rush to get it paid
if you if you haven't followed the right
process so by July I was quite heavily
pregnant and um I found out we had about
a million pounds worth of aged it
which is just it's like how just talk us
through that how did that feel sorry to
take you back there
that must have been like that was a
massive reality check for me I thought
um having a baby you know I've got I've
got my team in place you know I can kind
of take a bit more of a back seat no
came and it came at me fast it humbled
me massively and it forced me to have to
learn and I also found out about the
Dynamics in my business
um areas where people that were really
loyal to the business were unhappy
a lot came out from me coming back in
properly
and I'm now in hindsight I'm glad it
happened but at the time
it was like what is going on I was there
was a point where we didn't even have
money to pay the workers one week and
that that that that was horrible that
was really hard to come back from but
only had to manage that whilst like he
was literally what when when was your
son dude my son was due uh November 14th
well you liked this you had this moment
in July did you say so July August
September worst months of once ever
really
worse why didn't you quit then what what
no no
way all right that that's giving up it's
not in my it's not in my um it's not in
my nature to do that I as much as I
cried so much I and then I thought you
know what my son you know I did it for
my son as well I was just like my son
deserves me to push and the team that
actually have stood by me
you know deserves me to come back in and
do right by them as well so I pushed and
I pushed and I pushed and you know what
I the the first thing that I did when I
came back was sit in finance and that
was really bad I didn't want to wear for
a long time I started unraveling so much
and I just it was just coming at me
fishing fast and I thought oh my God but
I learned I learned about the invoice
discounting I learned about the um
payroll side of things I learned about
the the system that we use that why it's
not good for you know for for the
business I learned about the p l I
learned so the forecasting I learned
about the vat returns I learned about
you know our salaries and how we do our
salaries I learned so much and I also
sat and remember I said I was a debt
collector I was collecting the debt I
was very very yeah you recouped I I
recouped we we've got all our money back
we've managed to it was never lost money
no it's owed money owed money so some of
it could have been that the shifts
weren't on the system some of it could
have
it is lack of process as you said which
led to a build up of owed money yeah
yeah and our
I can't so how long was that whole
process would you say from like getting
your finally getting your financial hat
on committing to the things that you
weren't comfortable with had to learn to
then going on that whole journey of
recouping that we've
we've only just recovered from it so I
mean it's not too long ago is it really
no we've I think by the time I
um was having the baby I had brought in
a new group finance manager and he was
phenomenal I sat with him and I worked I
worked with him the entire time but the
difference this time around was I knew I
was talking about
um I could ask the relevant question so
was that the biggest lesson massive like
just basically instead of like at least
trying to get a good level of education
on it or understanding you sort of just
put buried your handed in the sand and
just I guess I'm assuming just like
stuck to what you're comfortable with if
I'm getting more there if we're doing
more deals then we are spending money
then surely like we're fighting yeah and
then you you really committed to
understanding
um and learning and then that enabled
you to yeah actually uncover what it is
that you needed but also hire the right
people hire the right people know what
it was that I was hiring I wrote the
JD's I knew what I needed in the
business so I went from not having you
know any understanding to writing a JDS
for what I wanted and Shout Out Amir as
well because I'm here he's my group
finance manager okay Reese both of them
they've done phenomenal business in
terms of turning around payroll and
putting the processes in and he has been
an amazing hire so I love that yeah it's
been it's been it's been a journey but
one worth
one worth talking about and then and
then just just is there anything else on
that then before we move on in terms of
the what like what you would do
differently like if you were to start
that bring in part of the finance
in-house again we've sort of learned
that yeah if you're going to do that
then it's a good idea to actually have
some sort of understanding even though
maybe it isn't your strongest suit like
you are uncomfortable trying to
understand financing these types of
things like is there anything else that
you would do differently
um take your time okay yeah plan
um make sure you have the right people
around you in terms of what you're
planning on doing and making sure it
makes sense so just um
sense checking your actual plan is
important because had I sat down and
actually thought about the full process
at the beginning of 2022 and what was
needed to be done I would have quickly
realized it's never going to be four
weeks that you can turn this around in
like why would I be giving that advice
and think that that's that's the right
advice it's not but again it's around
the people you hire as well I can't
can't say that enough if you've got the
wrong people around you and you don't
yourself know that area and you're led
by that you're gonna fail
so where where does this like not giving
up come from then I know because you
could have easily given up in those
periods do you know what it's the
responsibility of
you know my team and if it falls now
what was it done in vain you know like
what was the point of doing all of this
and now I'm Giving Up So I think that
strength comes just from
not wanting to go backwards and knowing
that the journey comes with many you
know
memorable bad times as well it's not
going to all be good it's not being an
MD is not a luxury I always say this to
people and they always say to me oh you
know you I want to be in your job and
I'm like trust me
you don't want to do it if you do want
to do it great but make sure you have
the the resilience for the the bad times
as well because it's not gonna all be
you know yeah big watches cars you know
big houses there's going to come a lot
of bad times as well and you've got to
be ready for those bad times because
when they come you know they come at you
fast and that's something that I haven't
been able to
sort of process as as much before in the
past I was like I'm an MD you know I'm
you know I'm doing well no you know now
the reality is kicked in I think I've
matured a lot more as well sort of um
putting this business together and each
year I'm learning something new so I
think
the role you're the first you know the
first one paying out last one to eat you
know that's just how it goes I mean I
don't know about all MDS but for me it's
so important that you know my team are
okay it's not just about me any longer
you know I've got my team who's got
families their livelihoods it's all
dependent on the decisions that I I make
so if I make a bad decision and we no
longer are in business then yeah you can
go and get another job but there's going
to be a period where some people might
not be able to get work or you know it's
just a lot of people depending on me and
I just feel like I feel very responsible
for that I feel like that's what's
driving me yeah so then now then what
what does what does Hannah do when like
[__] hits the fan then what what like
how do you deal with those dark days you
know what one thing my um partner will
say is that and forgive me to all my
clients that are not um you know hearing
me swear but my favorite saying is
[__] sake
I say it all the time and my partner
just laughs really it's always like [__]
sakes and like whenever something
happens there's a period of morning for
me and 24 hours normally okay let's just
have a day just to okay just get it out
your system get out of your system we go
we move we gotta we've got a you know
we've got an issue we've got to fix it
I'm just like how do I fix it what's the
solution so I give myself a day and then
I look at how I'm gonna fix it what I'm
gonna do to try and obviously make this
a better situation or scenario and if
it's something that's going to take a
little bit longer because I'm trying to
sometimes I think I try and fix things
too quickly sometimes you just gotta
take your time yeah just let it marinade
let it marinade think about it yeah yeah
quite a bit more if you need to whatever
it is you know I mean just just get it
out your system and then go back to it
with a with a level-headed mindset you
know what I'm saying so of that yeah
okay so let's just talk about them as
the sort of yeah I guess sort of final
part of this then let's talk about
Hannah also part of this juggling
um motherhood
I know that's something that
you wanted to talk about and is
important so I think so so like you said
so so basically I've got this post up
here that you shared yeah so
um so you welcomed kayamir that's my
baby boy your baby boy so when was he
born he was born on the 28th of October
28th of October that's my partner's
birthday yeah
yeah there we go so like talk me through
I mean look looking at this post here uh
wasn't the most straightforward
um I don't know if after birth or Jordan
buff I'm not sure but obviously he was
in the I.T who's with the itu team yeah
he was in to you and full y I didn't
have
have the best of experiences
um he had congenital pneumonia sorry
pneumonia so he had fluid in his lungs
so
um and I had to have a C-section so I
was a bit paranoid because I was working
a lot of hours and you know as I got
bigger I didn't feel her move as much so
um the hospital decided to induce me
early so he was he was due on the 14th
of November but they were like no we
need to induce you and my blood pressure
kept going up as well so a bit of a
traumatic experience for me to be honest
because um obviously not not planning
for a C-section I was like I'm gonna do
this naturally and I want to push and
all the rest of it but it's not down to
you it's down to your body and what your
body's capable of doing and you know
it's not something that I I was really
upset about it
and he was in you know it for a week and
that week for me was hell I really I was
in a really dark place
you know
um and just you know there was a lot
going on in the business there was a lot
of I suppose as I said before Sometimes
When You're vulnerable people sometimes
hone in on those vulnerabilities and
perhaps the structure that I had at the
time
didn't help so you know the team some of
the team that I had you know there was
people leaving in the business it just
all came at once
um
[Music]
but yeah he thankfully made full
recovery so he's all healthy if you see
my little boys that is the happiest
little boy you know he on my down days
he's literally the person that gets me
to sort of remember why I'm doing it you
know and then how how would you describe
like yeah now sort of one of the other
hats you know whereas is my is yeah
being a mum that's been as an MD that's
been a hard hard transition like I
um I urge any sort of entrepreneur sort
of mum female they're sort of doing sort
of business and and and and motherhood
postnatal depression is really a thing
you know I'm I'm going through that
myself currently so for people that may
not know what that is I'll speak to my
partner about this in preparation for
this so like in your own words from what
you've I guess learned about so far and
then we can talk about how you feel like
it has sort of showed up in your life
but like for those that may not heard
that word before I don't know like what
how would you describe postnatal of
depression just a dark a dark place dark
space you your moods are up and down
um sometimes it it might mean that you
don't connect with your child
um mine thankfully hasn't been that it's
just been about the trauma that he sort
of we experienced as you know because I
had a C-section
um
the fear of an anxiety that I have it's
it's always there like oh my God is he
okay can he is he is he is he breathing
okay you know some some nights I weren't
even able to sleep because I'll just be
watching him breathe just to make sure
he's breathing okay and then I'm just
consumed with my thoughts like you know
with the business as well I then have to
sort of go into to work mode in the
morning and you know people don't know
you've got to put on this front because
if they see that you're not you know
you're struggling
um they might not they might not believe
in the business any longer or might
think oh she's not got it anymore or you
know so there's all these all these
thoughts in my head like oh my God like
how am I gonna do this you know people
are leaving the business you know all
come at once and it got me very down it
really impacted on my relationship with
my partner
um
impacted on my own mental health because
my anxiety was was all over the place I
got to a point where I was having panic
attacks you know in the office
um it's a real thing like it's got a lot
better I even you know in December just
very recently I've recently been
discharged from the perinatal team
because I I went through that so what
does that mean sorry it's like a team
that sort of just it's like a perinatal
team and so what they're there to
support people that might be going
through the sort of things that you're
going through yeah new mums I was I felt
in despair really I felt like my whole
life was
it just changed overnight and I didn't
know how to sort of because I'm someone
that's so structured did you feel out of
control out of control and one thing
with me is I have to know what I'm doing
I need to have that that mindset of okay
tomorrow this is what I'm gonna do Etc
and it went out the window and I went
out the window with it if I'm you know
it was just not a good not a good not a
good time yeah because I was speaking to
my partner about this saying like I was
sitting down with you and this is
something you wanted to talk about so
obviously yeah I I obviously I can
listen and try and understand but I'm
never going to fully understand so I
sort of was asking her like what would
you be interested in
um sort of learning if someone's been on
that Journey so I think one one of the
questions that she said which I think is
quite interesting one to ask at this
point was obviously all those things
that you've been going through like
would you say that you'd suffered with
your mental health before
I've always been quite an anxious person
okay so I've always I've always and what
does that mean to you because we hear
that word a lot that means so when you
say you've always been a quite anxious
person how how has that showed up in
your life so very of critical cool very
much like am I doing enough am I doing
well I think it stems from you know
people's childhood for me it was
probably my childhood you know just
seeing my mum struggle you know working
two jobs not coming from an affluent
sort of background
um and just always saying to myself like
I don't want to do I don't want to
struggle like that I want to really work
hard and you know my mum worked really
hard and she did an amazing job with us
but I just don't want to go through
those struggles so was it this is really
interesting and you can let me know if
this resonates or not but it just
reminds me of a conversation I had that
was someone recently who also shared
this
um with me was is that like a bit of a
sense of like a fear of like losing it
all yeah that's what gets you up every
single morning because you've seen like
the hardship and not having whatever it
is so like it yeah yeah and you know
what it's not even about the material
Goods it's just about the
um the freedom to be able to do what you
want and if you don't have the funds or
the you know the you're not you don't
have the right level of capacity to be
able to do it you know it makes you
scared it makes me scared like every day
I'm like [__] like today I could you
know anything can happen so
and that fear drives me every single day
so it's a good thing and it's a bad
thing because if you let it consume you
it can completely mess with your mental
health and you need to have a balance
there are certain things that you're not
never going to be able to control and I
think
um I'm quite quite meticulous with how I
like to do stuff and I'd say maybe you
know oh it's borderline OCD no I like
structure I like to have
um you know day to day and I need to
know what I'm doing okay now how I'm
doing it you know my partner is the
opposite
so uh ironically enough he's he's the
opposite he's so laid back he's so
chilled and then you've got me who's
just like the drill sergeant
so what what have you then um look this
is an ongoing Journey right so like I
guess what do you feel like you've got
better at then you might be talking
about there but obviously going from
that dark place and things feeling
really difficult like how what sort of
things have you implemented what habits
I don't know is there anything that you
found okay so I've started therapy I
started therapy in December um so
obviously I had the perinatal team so I
was having some counseling about my son
and the trauma around that and then I
think I paid for myself to just go and
see someone privately and just sort of
delve into my past a bit more and asked
why am why am I the way I am right you
know what is it big question you know
yeah what makes what makes Hannah me
like Hannah
um and I think I found a few of the
reasons why I'm like this and why does
that help yeah it's really helped
because now it's just like I'm letting
go I'm Letting Go and
um I think this year the the main thing
with me is a lot of the time leading
with your emotions can be difficult as
well because well you found you did that
a lot one million percent like I would
always try and sort of I I would have
always trying to empathize with others
but maybe sometimes too much
um which could lead to the wrong
decisions being made or even people
taking advantage at times as well so
just just letting things letting things
go
um you know even in business you know if
something happens I'm a lot more chilled
about it now before what how you know
like I'm like this can't happen you know
but I'm I'm just taking it day by day
but in general I'm learning to let
things go that's amazing thank you for
sharing that and
how how have you found like because
again this is a journey but how have you
found juggling motherhood being a good
partner being an MD how have you found
that over the last yeah a couple of
months
struggle um
yeah just it's been really hard because
I haven't really taken any Matt leave to
be honest I've worked throughout
um and that's just because the business
wasn't in a good place when I was going
to have the baby and then obviously
after I had my son I had a couple of
weeks where I was home but to be honest
I was back in the office from December
and I was caught in my little man with
me he was coming to the business with me
so um because I it was not in a good
place and I felt I had to make sure that
we we you know did the necessary to to
get it out of that dark place as well so
I'm well I'm battling I've got you know
I've got issues with with
um the business I've got my son who I'm
now not even able to sleep because I'm
so anxious about him I'm trying to be a
you know a partner and you know keep
that alive yeah it's bloody hard yeah
look look this is the back to your point
right this is the reality of owning your
own company it's like the ultimate
response you have is the ultimate
responsibility yeah and sometimes we
a lot of time most MDS I don't know
about the others but some of the ones
I've met they're always fixes fixes yeah
fixes that's the role that they play
their fixes they fix things they make
sure that they lead from the front but
if there's a problem they're the first
to obviously deal with it and that is
such a huge responsibility and if you
see them driving a nice car they earn it
if you see them in a big house they earn
it you know what I'm saying so for me
now I see these things and I think it's
nice but actually the role is not a
luxury
some days I'm like when some of my team
are leaving at 5 30 I'm like [__] man I
wish I wasn't going too
I wish I love those 5 30 finishes you
know I want to go home I want to show I
just want to go and just watch a film
with my with my partner and just chill
out don't work like that
do you know what I'm saying it's not
like that for us it's you're always on
the go you're always having to think
ahead so some people might be looking
you know for today I'm looking I'm
already in June I'm already planning for
what's gonna happen in June in order to
be ahead so
it takes its toll no for honestly thank
you so much for being honest I know that
will yeah that'll be really helpful for
people
um to hear like just you talking about
honestly the journey the the trials and
tribulations yeah I guess just to sort
of wrap that up wrap that sort of part
up then and then let's just talk about
yeah what you're excited about this year
uh before we finish so what would you
say then for people listening out there
that do want a family
um that do
um yeah wanna sort of keep hold of their
career aspirations
um whilst becoming a mum I don't know is
there anything that yeah you'd share
with future mums maybe people that
already sort of pregnant and they're due
to be um mums very soon obviously yeah I
can only imagine how daunting that must
be so I don't know if there's anything
that you want to share with those people
that yeah obviously they've seen you
come out the other side and it's still
an ongoing Journey there's anything that
you can maybe share for people that
could be helpful yeah I would say that
your career is always going to be there
um so for a long time I mean I I'm you
know my I had my son at 36 and I didn't
really think about having children I
went I was waiting for the right time
there's never a right time just do it if
you're gonna if you really want to have
a child and just do it I would say my
advice is that your career will always
be there and if you are an ambitious
driven person your career you'll juggle
it you'll somehow juggle it and then
you'll ask yourself in a few years after
you've done it God how did I do that you
know what I'm saying so for me it's
important family is important for me so
important and I really want to make sure
that I don't because you know at the end
of the end of the day when you're going
home you want to go home to your family
and go home to the things that make you
happy in life and it's nice having a
business and stuff but if that's all
you're working for the hours the days
and nights it will pass and before you
know it you're 50 and you haven't done
certain things to kind of like make sure
that you've sort of embedded your fam
and and things that you think were
worthwhile and you're full resentful
you're full resentful so I am so
grateful for my son I think he gives me
a different sort of um
aspect in life I think he's made me more
chilled
foreign
he's given me a degree of patience I
didn't think I had
um I think I've always mothered a few
people in the business anyway so just
it's an extension of that so um I really
welcome him in my life I'm you know he's
the heir really he's the person who I
hopefully he'll be a footballer yeah uh
yeah Arsenal hopefully it'll be the next
yeah I hope he's exactly yeah I'm
rooting for him I'm rooting for him I
massage his legs every day every day I'm
massaging his little lips saying listen
these legs are going to be making me
some serious money
so no honestly like I I think motherhood
is is is it's difficult like I've been
openly speaking about the whole
postnatal depression thing as well
because people see me as this really
strong individual alpha female which I I
guess I am but you know be kind to us
too man because we also have times where
we're not in in good good space so
yeah so what we're saying for end of
2023 then obviously like watch your
absolute socks off you've got the
finance team in place you've got the
compliance team I've got my new head of
operations what are we saying where are
we going to end 2023 then oh mate HD
group HD group is going to be we're
going to be hitting some serious
Milestones nursing is going to just be
even bigger than it is now we're going
to do um home care we're just going to
just try and tap into all of the areas
that we've we've sort of committed to at
the start of this year
um and we're going to grow the
management team we're going to give more
people opportunities we're going to
invest in individuals who want to
basically Branch out on their own as
well
um so it's positive times man because I
feel like there's so many there's enough
room for everyone to sort of be on you
know on a certain journey and make money
and do well and also if they want to be
owners of businesses why not like why
can't we sort of facilitate that like
that yeah let's do it love that Handler
absolute pleasure utmost respect thank
you for having me no thanks for being
nothing short of honest authentic I
think uh a lot of people can learn a lot
from your journey I think you're going
to a lot of people and yeah like really
um really respect sort of just you being
honest and being real I think it's
really important so keep being you thank
you very much for having me honestly I
really appreciate you bringing me here
thank you so much for listening to the
episode I hope you enjoyed it and got
value from the conversation if you did
enjoy it please don't forget to like
share and subscribe and we'll see you in
the next episode